now he's beginning his big big and most
important journey this is where you were
meant to be right here today at this
crossroads in history I'm still here
nothing has changed I've said 2018 is a
year of execution my Commission the
Secretary of State will terminate at
midnight March the 31st we got along
actually quite well but we disagreed on
things so we were not really thinking
the same
well the timeline we have is that the
chief of staff called the Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson while he was
overseas and said get ready you need to
either step down or the president is
going to act the president did act via
Twitter was the first acknowledgment
officially saying Mike Pompeo director
of the CIA will become our new Secretary
of State he will do a fantastic job
thank you to Rex Tillerson for his
service Geena Haspel will become the new
director of the CIA the first woman so
chosen congratulations to all four
months plus ago Twitter was a place
where the president took to to defend
Rex Tillerson from stories that he was
on his way out the door
media has been speculating that I fired
Rex Tillerson or that he would be
leaving soon fake news he's not leaving
and while we disagree on certain
subjects I call the final shots we work
well together in America is highly
respected again there have been a number
of high-profile Trump administration
officials of resigning or being fired
and the list is continuing and there you
see just some of them the question is
will it continue this shake-up and what
does it mean for this administration
let's bring in our panel Steve Hays
editor in chief for the Weekly Standard
AV Stoddard associate editor at
RealClearPolitics and host of No Labels
radio on Sirius XM and Charles hurt
opinion editor for The Washington Times
Charlie well it is kind of interesting
fight that it was what five months ago I
think you just read that tweet from
Donald Trump five months is an eternity
in this administration one week seems
like an eternity so it is and so you
know so I think that so I think that
maybe maybe the Twitterverse was getting
it wrong there five months ago but but I
you know this notion that Donald Trump
doesn't like you know that he has to
surround himself by yes-man in the
argument that they use for why he likes
separate is surround himself by yes-man
he's by pointing to all of the know men
that he has around him and yes down from
fired Rex Tillerson today but they've
clearly had a very serious issue
disagreements for a very long time he
the president mentioned Iran today the
and and I think that you know obviously
the the differences were unbridgeable
and that's why he made this decision but
I do think that it's important remember
he he doesn't surround himself by
yes-man he does have people like Jim
mattis like Gary Cohn who disagreed with
him on tariffs but but they got a lot
done together III just kind of find that
that particular accusation to be
unfounded there was reported a suicide
pact if you would between Tillerson and
mattis and I think minuchin at one that
obviously we don't know about that now
and now that Tillerson is effectively
leaving if you put up the bullet points
of disagreements rifts if you will the
Iran nuclear deal is number one North
Korea's strategy they were on different
pages even this week with that the Qatar
blockade China policy Russian meddling
and initial response to the poisoned
Russian spy tariffs big big riff there
the Paris climate agreement and the
Charlottesville response man they were a
number of them it's interesting maybe
that that it started out that Tillerson
was said to be so close to Russia and
Putin friend and as he's leaving he is
the guy who's standing up talking about
Russian interference and that's why he's
leaving according to some well everyone
looks aggressive on Russia next to the
president but I think if you put mattis
up right now you'd find you'd have a
bunch of bullet points on which he
disagrees people in this administration
and national security and foreign policy
have spoken on separate pages from the
West Wing many times it's really a
hallmark of this first year-plus
you know
from Pompeo and Haspel and people who
are going to take these positions how
much how little Rex Tillerson we miss at
the State Department how long this was
coming
it was obviously untenable and a
president and a secretary of state can't
disagree that much on policy and it has
to work so it has to be he has to be
replaced it's the way that he did it I
think today is a really dark day for
this country I think it reflected very
poorly on us
unlike Charlie I'm Pro stability and it
was the way that he did it by
humiliating him and which is cruel and
unnecessary and the timing I think with
the north why didn't he do it six weeks
ago the timing with the North Korea
summit I think is terrible so the
further destabilization and dysfunction
of this government is always an
advantage to our adversaries and that
just seems to be a constant theme and I
find it frightening well Steve you know
how it was done obviously secretary of
Tillerson today did not mention
President Trump and his remarks as he
was exiting the State Department which
is notable on the Iran deal if passing
Senate nomination hearings and a vote
director Pompeo has a long history of
opposing this Ron deal I asked him about
it in an interview not too long ago when
you were congressman Pompeo I asked you
about the Iran nuclear deal
here's what you said is there anything
congressman that is good out of this
deal but I can't think of a thing not
one I can't think of a thing that has
put America in a better position as a
result of this deal now the president
has this decision whether to reauthorize
Derron nuclear deal do you have a
different perspective today produce it
in a different place and so my role is a
bit different this is what I would say
the president's made clear his view that
he doesn't think the deal was worth a
darn
and that's Pompey's view too it seems
like we're closer to getting out of the
Iran deal today than we were a week ago
yeah I think the more likely scenario
rather than a full withdrawal will be a
some kind of attempt at a follow-on
agreement where you pressure France
Germany and the United King
into snapback sanctions and a series of
other things that might make the deal
more enforceable snap inspections of
military sites things that we're not
able to do right now and I believe
Pompeo is actually in favor of that
policy as opposed to just walking away
from the deal but what's been
interesting is Mike Pompeo has seen
himself he's a West Point grad who takes
seriously these different lanes as CIA
director he was not a policy advisor to
the president and in their meetings he
repeatedly sought first to provide the
president with intelligence in a non
policy way and Donald Trump would come
back to Mike Pompeo in these meetings
and then ask him for Policy advice which
was a little bit of an uncomfortable fit
I think Pompey was very close to
president Trump philosophically on this
range of issues and in that sense he'll
be a lot I think he'll be a more serious
advisor to the president than Rex
Tillerson was Rex toes have disagreed
with the president so many times on so
many things the president just stopped
listening to him in this instance you
have somebody who's smart who's
thoughtful who knows these issues very
well and who will have the president's
ear I mean Mike Pompeo has become a
trusted adviser to Donald Trump I think
the president also trusts Gina Hass ball
she was been giving him when Pompey was
gone his P D B's they've developed a
relationship residential Daily Brief
they've developed a relationship as well
she's well respected inside the CIA I
think the baby's right about the
processing the process here is a
disaster and it's not surprising but the
outcome I think is not it is a good
outcome is there any doubt that this is
going to be that Democrats are gonna try
to use these hearings for you know a
number of different things but is there
any doubt that they both of these folks
can get through
Pompeyo and hospital I think even Haspel
who has the bigger problems because of
her involvement in in
the the enhanced interrogation technique
stuff has more of an uphill battle but
I'm from my conversations with people on
the hill today even she will get through
with some Democratic votes and maybe
lose some Republican votes but that she
will get through maybe no I agree I
think she's gonna be made to respond
about black sites and enhanced
interrogation techniques from a long
time ago at her hearing and they'll move
on I don't think that she's gonna be
opposed anything can happen
yeah she could end up with a gambling
problem or being investigated for
financial crimes by the Department of
Homeland Security but you know at this
point I think it looks fine for her all
right fantastic Pompeo is confirmed I
mean the question for is how many
Republicans she loses I think there's a
chance she loses John McCain Rand Paul
Lindsey Graham maybe Mike Lee and how
many Democrats she can gain you've had
somewhat positive things said about her
by some Democrats on the Intelligence
Committee worked with her Dianne
Feinstein who was a fierce opponent of
enhanced interrogation so that she's got
a no Gina Haspel and has talked to her
about these things I think it's a close
vote but I think she ultimately is
confirmed